will the fourth wall ever get fixed the
ending of She-Hulk Attorney-at-Law took
the MCU to Wild New Frontiers
from the beginning of She-Hulk Jennifer
Walters wants us to know that this isn't
a superhero show it's a lawyer show the
first episode shows her in her element
practicing closing arguments in her
office before heading to court since she
knows the majority of us watch MCU
movies for the heroics of Larger than
Life characters she turns to the camera
and agrees to tell us her secret origin
just to get it out of the way
it's true I am a Hulk uh and I'm
guessing you're not going to be able to
focus on this fun lawyer show until you
know all about that so let me get you up
to speed after we learn about the car
accident with her cousin Bruce and his
blood accidentally falling into her
wound and Bruce fails to train her
Jennifer enthusiastically exclaims that
this is now a lawyer show then Titania
bursts through the wall and forces Jen
to Hulk out revealing her secret to the
world in a lot of ways that is what the
show is about Jennifer Walters refusal
to be a superhero and determination to
just be a really good lawyer this idea
comes back in various forms throughout
the series but the finale really hits at
home when she flat out delivers a
closing argument defending her right to
want her show to be something new and
different in the MCU in this way the
series basically serves as an argument
as to why new and different kinds of
stories can and should exist within the
superhero space
another important theme moving through
She-Hulk is that of Second Chances the
most obvious example of this is the
character of Emile Blonsky who is
Jennifer's first client once she gets
the job at the law offices of GLK and H
the character was first introduced to
the MCU in 2008's The Incredible Hulk in
which he signs up to receive the super
soldier serum which ultimately turns him
into the abomination in that film he's
clearly depicted as the villain but in
She-Hulk attorney at law he argues that
he was the victim of a botched
experiment carried out by the American
government and that he's changed
Jennifer is suspicious of a meal but
Bruce assures everyone that they've
buried the hatchet and that he too is a
different man now yes this is an obvious
reference to the fact that the Hulk was
played by Edward Norton in the 08 film
but it's also a statement on how people
can change over time aside from the
various antagonists who get Second
Chances Jennifer has to learn to give
her new identity a second chance as well
which we see in the scene where Matt
Murdock explains that she has the
incredible opportunity to help people
both in the courtroom and in the real
world
when Jennifer is infected by Bruce's
blood it throws a wrench into her entire
life she had her own career and her own
life and now she's forced to live with a
power that she wants nothing to do with
it's a common Trope in superhero stories
but for her it's a curse not only can
she no longer live her normal life but
everyone insists on comparing her to her
cousin Jennifer Walters also known as
She-Hulk rumored to have been rejected
by The Avengers the minute she reveals
herself in court to stop Titania from
hurting people Jennifer obliterates her
anonymity to make matters worse her
identity quickly gets co-opted by the
media who claim her to be nothing more
than the female version of her cousin by
the end of the series Jennifer is so fed
up with everyone comparing her to Bruce
that she literally rewrites the ending
everything's in place to have Bruce and
Jennifer fight Hulk King side by side
but that would only further the
misconception that she's just a lady
Hulk so she shuts that down and refuses
to allow her show to end in the usual
Marvel third act action sequence
the villain of She-Hulk isn't someone
you can just haul off and punch in the
face several times like the version of
the Mandarin we got at the end of Iron
Man 3 she-hulk's Nemesis is more of a
concept than it is a specific individual
although there is someone at the center
of it all that is primarily responsible
for all the horrible things that happen
to her Intelligentsia is a website
predominantly made up of men who can't
stand the fact that a woman got cool
superpowers and they didn't a lot like
certain groups on the actual internet
they complain about being victims
claiming that She-Hulk is strutting
around with abilities that she doesn't
deserve they feel betrayed and
disenfranchised and they take out that
anger by shaming her online and
threatening to kill her as evidenced
perfectly by the vitriol that's been
leveraged at the show by a subset of
viewers since its announcement this kind
of response is far from fantasy from
start to finish the series makes a point
of showing the real world trends that
allow groups like Intelligentsia to
flourish
Bruce Banner had to struggle for years
to find peace with his alter ego through
his dialogue and She-Hulk attorney at
law we learned that for him the Hulk
truly is another being living inside him
after merging with that being Bruce is
finally able to find Solace he tries to
help Jennifer do the same but she
doesn't really need his help
triggers are anger and fear those are
like the Baseline of any woman just
existing people are always ready to
knock her down take advantage of her or
just assume they know more than she does
since she spent her entire life coming
to grips with that she doesn't need the
same training to control her moods that
Bruce does instead her struggle isn't
accepting the fact that she can
transform at all again once she changes
she becomes a public figure and when
you're a public figure the millions of
strangers who know your name and image
decide who and what you are Jennifer
argues over and over again that she
isn't She-Hulk she's just Jennifer
Walters only when she's able to embrace
her new public Persona thanks in part to
a little advice from Daredevil can she
finally stride into the courthouse at
the end with real confidence even though
the media immediately accuses her of
being a diva Titania is set up as the
villain of the series pretty early on
when she smashes through the wall of the
courtroom before Jen can deliver her
closing argument and win the case their
fight is the inciting incident of the
entire series because that action
results in Jen revealing her green self
to the world and the morons who post on
Intelligentsia to Rally together to take
her down then she disappears for a while
when she shows back up she has
trademarked the name She-Hulk making us
think that she has some diabolical plan
to take She-Hulk down in a public forum
but that doesn't happen either finally
they meet again in the flesh at a
wedding for Jen's high school friend but
the fight doesn't quite go the way we
expect either then just before the
climax of the series pops off she shows
up to throw down with everyone else but
the show takes a drastic left turn by
the end she's just another person
standing around with nothing to do while
Titania could be plotting something else
the fact of the matter is that she's a
nobody she's a person who learned how to
manipulate public interest into making a
profit by flaunting her wealth Her Image
and selling people bottles filled with
nothing she is basically who the
intelligencia poster think She-Hulk is
Jennifer Walter's love life is an
absolute disaster she's too busy for
relationships and once she becomes
She-Hulk men are more interested in her
green form than her human form she
thinks men don't want the real her they
just want the idealized version of her
still she decides to use that to her
advantage and sets up some dates the
first guy she takes home is nice enough
at first but once he sees her human form
he loses interest in her the second is a
certifiable Monster who films himself
having sex with Jen without permission
takes photos of her while she's sleeping
and then steals all the information on
her phone so by the time she meets a
blind lawyer named Matt Murdoch from
Hell's Kitchen AKA Daredevil she's
pretty done with relationships for the
time being however Matt manages to see
her more clearly than anyone else he's
uniquely suited to understand her
struggle because he's also living a
double life so he gets a bit of what
she's going through in addition to their
romantic connection he helps her
understand that there is a way to use
her double life to help people so she
never has to give up who she is
If She Hulk has a singular villain then
it's the loser named Todd Phelps who
dubs himself Hulk King at first he's
just one of many dates Jen goes on and
while his personality is played for
Laughs there's something unsettling
about the way he speaks and Carries
himself things take a turn later when he
reveals himself to be the guy behind
Intelligentsia and that he set up Josh
to infiltrate Jen's life and wreck it he
doesn't see her as a human being as far
as he's concerned she's a giant green
reminder of everything he's not he's not
confident he's not powerful he's a petty
childish and dangerous sexist who
assumes he's destined for greatness and
can't bear the fact that a woman has
powers she didn't even want that's why
he tries to dismantle her life and take
her blood he wants to be the Hulk we
expect there to be a big throw down when
he hulks out but Jennifer pulls a Twist
and just changes the trajectory of the
episode
the ending of She-Hulk is certainly
strange but it makes perfect sense for
the show this is a character who's
trying to be one thing but everyone else
wants her to be something else she
doesn't want to be a superhero but Bruce
tries to make her one she doesn't want
to go public but Titania screws that up
she wants to be respected as a lawyer
but her boss and the media are
determined to make her a freak Show when
The Narrative of the series turns into a
big punch Fest she can't take it anymore
and literally steps outside her show to
confront Marvel Studios president Kevin
feige himself in AI form through this
bizarre twist Jen takes Back The
Narrative of her own series and her life
in general
and enough with this angsty night time
let's do this big climax in daylight
she's been the pawn in other people's
stories for too long and she decides to
take back what's hers some viewers might
find the ending is so unconventional
that it puts them off the show but after
considering all of the show's meta
commentary it's an oddly perfect way to
wrap things up
She-Hulk attorney at law wouldn't be a
proper MCU show if it didn't spend some
time setting up future stories after Jen
rewrites the episode and makes sure that
everyone gets some kind of Arc she winds
up back home with her parents for a
celebratory barbecue of course they want
to know everything about her life and
especially her new beau Matt as everyone
sits down to their meal Bruce shows up
in his Hulk form and apologizes for
being away on sakkar for so long
promising to let us know all about it in
the future the show even gives us a
little tease as to what happened there
when Bruce introduces his son Scar the
character of Scar first appears in what
if Planet Talk number one before joining
the Marvel Universe proper following the
world war Hulk storyline in the comics
he's born to the Hulk and his wife kyera
on sakar scar ages quickly and becomes
an adult in no time just as he appears
in She-Hulk his presence in the show
suggests that the next Bruce Banner
story we get might be an MCU
approximation of that same storyline
it's a bit confusing at first when we
see Emile Blonsky locked up in She-Hulk
attorney at law given that the last
place we saw him was fighting Wong in a
cage in chongqi in the legend of the ten
Rings the series explains that Wong
broke a meal out in order to have
someone to spar with but that Emil
returned to his cell to serve out his
sentence afterward like the reformed man
he is at the end of the She-Hulk finale
we see Emil locked up yet again this
time for violating his parole by
transforming into the Abomination Wong
then shows up to break him out again
Emilio my apologies for Italy yeah you
got sucked in another show didn't you is
abomination asking Wong if he's binging
a new TV program or hinting at the idea
that he and Wong could appear in another
MCU show in the near future for now
that's one of the big unanswered
questions in She-Hulk
[Music]